[Risas]
[Música]
el día de hoy yo quiero invitarles a un
viaje maravilloso a los antes
quiero por favor que por un momento
todos todas se concentren
y piensen en 4000 metros
unas montañas maravillosas
un viento fuerte que te va a tocar las
mejillas
te despierta
te hace sentir viva vivo
es nuestro primer viaje de vinculación
con la sociedad
y vamos a estar con una comunidad de
altura
en efecto cuatro horas más tarde
llegamos a esta comunidad
mucha gente sale a recibirlos con
sonrisas amabilidad
y todos nos dan la mano uno por uno
algo que no podríamos hacer en este
momento verdad
entre toda la gente se acerca un siglo
una persona mayor
que todos llaman tan bajos
a veces nosotros lo hicimos software
talca jorge es el fundador de esta
comunidad
nos invitan a pasar a la casa comunal
y estábamos con una gran familia todos
reunidos empieza a contarnos cómo fue la
fundación de la comunidad porque
tuvieron que subir a esta altura para
poder tener un espacio una tierra
nos cuenta también sobre todos los
problemas que han tenido y que tienen
el rata de agua no hay hay poca
producción
porque la tierra está muy ilusionada y
luego el cambio climático
luego de recordarnos toda esta historia
mucho detalle con los días que subieron
que llegaron quienes fueron cuantos
estuvieron
decide compartir con nosotros algunas de
las historias del lugar los pk varios
iba jugando con chicha y el español en
español en dicho
nosotros empezamos a quedarnos prendado
de una historia
el ática y la tumba
según él nos decía en un animal fuerte
grande
muy suspicaz
y quería cantar como un pajarito que se
llama solitario
nos cuenta el fin que nunca aprendió a
cantar
nos había mostrado tanto la historia que
mientras le iba contando nosotros
tomábamos notas tomábamos fotos de todo
el ambiente hacían los pequeños
bosquejos y dibujos porque empezamos a
pensar que esta historia era estupenda
para poder crear un producto que fuese
significativo para la comunidad
este vídeo no es un bendito bien
con todos estos datos y una vez que se
acabó la reunión y conversamos
los despedirnos de la gente y salimos
tan contentos porque teníamos en la mano
todo este maravilloso material que nos
ayudaría en este objetivo que nos
habíamos trazado
blanquito empezamos a trabajar con los
materiales y nos unimos dos veces
logramos un producto que creemos que era
realmente estupendo para la comunidad
se trataba de un librito sobre el azúcar
a todo color
y habíamos conseguido que alguien nos
financiará poder entregar un cuento a
cada familia no podíamos pedir más
organizamos nuestro segundo viaje
a esta comunidad
cuando llegamos y estábamos todos tan
contentos nosotros porque íbamos a dar
algo inolvidable a la comunidad y pues
la comunidad porque les estábamos
visitando
y les íbamos a dar esta sorpresa
empezó la reunión en la misma casa
comida
con toda la comunidad allí reunida
y nosotros empezamos a contarles sobre
el átomo que habíamos hecho que habíamos
creado ya mostrarles de librito hoja por
hoja yo tenía el libro así en mis manos
iba abriendo las hojas
y mostrar a todos
mientras tanto una chica joven de la
comunidad iba leyendo en dicho
son
para mí era tan emocionante poder tocar
este libro ir abriendo mostrarles a
todos
sin embargo a medida que yo avanza va
con él y no notaba que la gente no
estaba tan contenta
que tenían una expresión de duda casi de
desconcierto me imaginaba que se estaban
preguntando qué nos estaban contando
qué están diciendo
pero claro yo seguí prácticamente este
final
y cuando estábamos listos para empezar a
entregar los libros
y el equipo se iba acercando a las
familias yo escuché un bajito
en mi lado derecho una voz que me decía
gigante atajos
y me dijo oiga yo creo que este lobito
debe ser muy viejo
yo soy bien viejo el más viejo de toda
la comunidad pero yo he conocido un
hábito así que extraño
créame cuando me dijo eso yo sentí una
angustia en el estómago
y prácticamente me paralicé lo único que
se me ocurrió hacer es un papel un
lápiz y decirle a jorge cuando su lobito
y talca jorge empezó a dibujar
borrar las dibujaba borraba dibujaba yo
miraba sí un poquito del reloj o
y me sorprendía cada vez más
cuando me simplemente no dibujo
examiné y me di cuenta rápidamente de
esta equivocación que habíamos cometido
el acto era un solo amigo
y suspicaz el absorben vivo obvio era un
submarino porque estábamos solos antes
pero nosotros en nuestra imaginación en
nuestro deseo de hacer algo hermoso que
habíamos hecho habíamos hecho un claro
lobo
yo no de pelaje propio de las estepas
europeas
se terminó la reunión todos nos
agradecieron por el libro
pero nosotros estábamos angustiados
estamos frustrados porque sentíamos que
no había funcionado este sueño de éxito
que teníamos con la entrega
salimos de la comunidad y para no ser la
primera colina que encontramos
es que necesitábamos conversar
necesitábamos
entender necesitamos llorar y entre
lágrimas y frases desordenadas
desordenadas empezamos a decir
como es posible algo tan bonito
no sólo les gustó
es que no puede ser posible
nosotros tomamos datos tomamos fotos
diseñamos esto con tanta paciencia y
está a todo color
no es posible tanto trabajo tanto
esfuerzo tanta dedicación dos meses
perdidos
en medio de estas quejas
y nos dimos cuenta que lo único que
estábamos haciendo era hablar
desde nosotros
desde ese interior frustrado que
teníamos porque no habíamos llegado al
éxito
habíamos trazado
y nuestro ego académico estaba
profundamente
cuando hablamos así nos dimos cuenta
que tenemos que presionar el error
estaba en que verdaderamente cuando
habíamos ido a hacer
estas actividades de relación con la
comunidad de vinculación con la
comunidad
nos habíamos vinculado
no nos habíamos relacionado
habíamos invisibilizado
a toda la gente
la habíamos quizás mirado a la distancia
y la habíamos confundido con el paisaje
que estaba por detrás
habíamos sido sordos a los detalles de
talca jorge repetía y repetía
no nos habíamos situado
en donde debíamos situarnos que era los
andes 4000 metros la comunidad con la
que queremos conversar
no habíamos conversado
habíamos tenido monólogos
como auschwitz
que creen que están comunicándose cuando
en verdad están incomunicados
les ha pasado que confunden un lobo con
un zorro
muchas muchas veces hacemos demasiadas
veces
y por supuesto habrá gente que me dice y
qué importa si es lo es oro a quién le
importa
y a nosotros si de verdad queremos
trabajar con ellos y avanzar con ellos y
aprender intercambiar reflexionar
dialogar
esa fue una elección muy dura
luego de estas heridas profundas que
habíamos recibido
nos dimos cuenta que la única forma de
trabajar en colaboración y con respecto
es despojarnos de toda esta colonialidad
que nos ha formado
o quizás debemos decir que no se ha
deformado
debemos votar este es el turismo que nos
maneja que nos manipula y que nos hace
pensar
que siempre tenemos la razón que sabemos
todo que tenemos la respuesta correcta
que creemos que la gente con la que
vamos a trabajar
estaba cierre conocimientos
cuando bien sabemos que cada uno de
nosotros todo todo ser humano tiene una
historia tiene experiencias
conocimientos vivencias vidas
solamente si logramos renacer
y buscamos la forma de intercambiar
equitativa equitativamente
de reflexionar
de tratar de entender y de respetar
solamente así podremos trabajar
hermanados tomados de la mano o del
brazo
y mirando juntos hacia un futuro
hace unos hombre
que entendemos mejor
solamente así podremos auto reconocerlos
auto analizarlos y auto empoderarnos
investigar no es fácil
vincularse con comunidades o con el loto
que no conocemos
no es fácil
son procesos largos de lecciones
difíciles
pero solamente si las aprendemos
lograremos vivir auténticamente en la
diversidad
en esta universidad que es la que nos
rodea
don jorge se nos fue tempranamente
se llevó con el conocimientos
invaluables
pero dejó a su familia
a sus hijos a sus cimientos a los amigos
una comunidad
una tierra
para poder trabajar la isla
nos de jugar nosotros
unas lecciones
una graves
lecciones no solo de trabajo
no lecciones que se escriben en papel
lecciones profundas de vida
una vez que las hayamos aprendido
tenemos
apegarnos a ellos
y trabajar con ellas
son más y avanzaremos en el futuro
recuerden sin embargo que el futuro es
oro
entonces si estamos listos a vivir en
esta rica diversidad y entender a loco y
respetar al loco y reflexionar
conjuntamente entonces vamos empecemos
hoy
porque el futuro empieza hoy
muchas gracias